hey is Tommy and Luke and Nathan here
with the outdoor boys youtube channel
and today we're playing with dry eyes oh
oh we got dry ice here hold on I'm going
to make you some magic Greek there you
go yea-ah
[Music]
working when I put my mouse on it it
closed on my mouth can't stomach yell I
add you ready to go sir nope eat well
oh yeah we'll watch this guy don't touch
it don't touch it
okay okay take this down
so got some dry ice in the cider and
what we're going to do you do this watch
this guy's see watch this now you don't
want to do this with a whoa just a
little love where'd that let go this is
a real dangerous game if you do it too
much the thing explodes on your hand
just let it have a little bit of
pressure then occasionally just take
your hand dogs you do this in a pressure
cooker it works well we'll do this one
is number four now when will they come
around it's good a little bit carbonated
why me look at Nathan there's like some
apple slushy in there it's apples plus
you want try some no Barry
[Music]
daddy nap but my dream it's gone forever
whoa you wanna see something cool
dry-ice sinks be dry ice doesn't float
like water ice beauty does sinking when
this boy Brussels yeah just getting in
there it the pieces of dry ice are on
the bottom that crazy cries right there
[Music]
yeah look at that as apple cider slushy
good may want to be careful because dry
ice will give you frostbite on your
fingers or your tongue so don't hold dry
ice in your mouth or hold it in your
hands it don't raise your fingers does
school
ciders lessee whatever oh I got me I
held it too much and it just CrossFit me
right there got to be careful
give me more apples lemon sure I'll get
to some more apple cider and then let me
pick off a piece of dry aizen ready to
do it without getting across my to get
stop okay I can't worry what's country
but I there for me ah there you got a
piece in there there's a piece in there
now go for it I see the ice it's on the
bottom usually that ice goes on the
bottom so as long as you don't tip it
upside down we just sip it it shouldn't
the I shouldn't touch your lips if it I
said still up here you get frostbite
feels like it burns you actually it's
it's not subtle at all it's like Bing
yeah touching the dry ice is kind of
it's a bad idea don't touch it with your
hands it'll give you frostbite and
actually search but sometimes when you
touch it wet it's like the moisture
around it makes a layer of gas so it's
like you're not touching it but you are
then it kind of hurts you edge it's kind
of a funky experience we started using
Amazon grocery delivery service and when
they deliver your cold products to your
door has dry ice in the bag so we've
been playing with dry ice a lot lately
it's been fun there's just one chunk
left there we go don't touch it with
your fingers it'll it will roll in
couple ways and you're all thinking of
these little pieces of dry ice is kind
of like putting out a candle flame with
your fingers
I kind of do it just right it's not bad
but everyone's on all gifts you all
right there we go there's still dry ice
here but the it's so cold that the cider
around it turns to ice and then it stops
reacting it kind of makes a little
insulation around ya see it's still
going and still the dry ice is still in
there it's just kind of covered in the
little coat of ice it insulates it you
got to be careful because if you bite
into one of those tongues of slushy and
there's a piece of dry ice in the middle
that it can free up Foss by your tongue
but I live on the edge like danger
anytime you want to throw it watch this
we're going to little ice hey that's how
we have a good time on a Wednesday night
at the Nichols home now some of you
might have heard about making dry-ice
bombs you take a piece of dry ice and
you put it in the water bottle and you
seal the top and shake it up and the gas
expands the bottle until it explodes
now while this might be very
entertaining stuff to do in the state of
Virginia that is considered bomb-making
and is a felony and I actually have
defended people who have been arrested
because they thought it was a good idea
to make dry-ice bombs and they got
caught and as a criminal defense
attorney I can tell you if you're going
to break the law don't post it on
YouTube so we are not making dry-ice
bombs one because I don't want plastic
shards going in my children's faces and
two because I don't want to be arrested
when I post this video when I write I
hope you guys like this video and hope
you had a good time watching it just a
little goofing around if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel don't forget to
kid do you want the apples right